[Music]
on this Friday night a preliminary
ruling in the genocide case against
Israel the orders from the un's top
court and Israel cannot be accepted from
comping the decision significance where
it falls short and how Canada is
reacting breaking news the verdict is in
a jury decides the fate of Donald Trump
at his defamation trial the escalating
battle at the border between Texas and
Mexico Governor Abbott is getting in the
way the US Supreme Court's decision and
the state's
Defiance wrestling Titan Vince McMahon
hit with a federal lawsuit a former
employees graphic and grizzly claims
against the WWE
founder and putting their best foot
forward in Canada for us it's a very big
opportunity Ukraine's national ballet
dances for
democracy
global national with foreign Asser
reporting tonight n gcha good evening
and thanks for joining us the
international court of justice has
delivered a much anticipated ruling
demanding Israel do more to contain the
death and damage its military operation
has brought to
Gaza Israel must in accordance with its
obligations under the genocide
convention in relation to Palestinians
in Gaza take all measures within its
power to prevent the commission of all
acts within the scope of article two of
the convention South Africa brought
forth the law suit alleging the war in
Gaza amounts to genocide against
Palestinians Israel has vehemently
rejected the accusation calling the case
outrageous its national security
minister responding bluntly to today's
ruling on social media saying the hag
schag the reaction to the Court's
decision is widespread including here in
Canada where members of the liberal
government remain divided more on that
in a moment we start in the heg with a
ruling that may lack immediate practical
consequences in Gaza but could
ultimately hold deep historical
resonance for people on all sides of
this conflict Chrystal ganing begins our
coverage all measures the panel of
international judges was sitting in the
he when celebrations began in South
Africa the court shared two decisions it
stated the case alleged Israel violated
the genocide convention in Gaza would
proceed and the court ordered Israel to
take a number of immediate and effective
measures they include getting urgently
needed basic services and humanitarian
assistance to Palestinians the court
said Israel needs to prevent and punish
the direct and public incitement to
commit genocide in the Gaza Strip and
prevent the destruction and ensure the
preservation of evidence related to the
larger Case by South Africa Israel has
very powerful friends who I hope uh will
advise Israel that they should act the
international court of justice orders
are legally binding but there's no means
of enforcement this is what Israel's
prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu had to
say Israel's commitment to international
law is
unwavering equally unwavering is our
sacred commitment to continue to defend
our country and defend our people the
fact that Israel was not ordered to Halt
its military operations in Gaza could
have been a strategic move by the court
says this former Canadian foreign
minister it's a question of how do you
do it and you can't do it uh with a wide
openen uh shoot him up kind of
arrangement you're going to have to
really live by the the rules and the
laws of the Geneva Convention bring them
home Netanyahu called the charge of
genocide false and outrageous he and
supporters outside the court pointed to
the horrific crimes committed by Hamas
and the hostages still being held issues
the court addressed it is Gravely
concerned about the fate of the hostages
abducted during the attack in Israel on
7 October
2023 the court taking action after
multiple votes of the UN Security
Council going nowhere is considered by
some a means of reestablishing faith and
trust in international rules of law
there was however something missing for
this human rights lawyer one of the
measures that that wasn't implemented
was to allow a fact finding Mission um
in um to to to report back um I think
that that is a failure by the court more
provisional measures could still be
added Israel was instructed to report
back in one month's time showing how it
has addressed the Court's orders nethu
crystal ganing in London thanks Crystal
prime minister Justin Trudeau previously
said Canada is watching the case
carefully and stands behind the
international court but despite today's
ruling the federal government still
isn't offering a clear stance toward the
allegations against Israel as McKenzie
gray reports that hasn't stopped
divisions around the issue from arising
within the liberal caucus
itself com on the icj
ruling it's something the Prime Minister
really didn't want to talk about Justin
Trudeau dodging questions four separate
times to on what cada's position is on
the international court of justice
ruling no comment though it wasn't until
late this afternoon the foreign affairs
minister commented recycling her old
lines on the case our support for the
icj does not mean that we accept the
premise of the case brought by South
Africa Melanie joli said in a statement
it is for the icj to make a final
decision on the case which it is not
done today we continue to follow the
case very
closely liberal MPS have followed the
case showing a caucus divided the court
did not take a position on whether or
not Israel is committing genocide my
position has been that Israel is not
committing genocide that it's baseless
and it's insult thing I'm a bit
disappointed that like they didn't ask
for a immediate ceasefire but what they
have said in making sure that
humanitarian Aid gets through Raza
civilians are protected and I hope
Israel will abide by that
representatives from both Israel and the
Palestinians found common ground on
wanting to know what the Canadian
government thinks of the ruling we call
on Canada to the leader and champion of
the international rules based order our
position is that we call on the
International Community to on the face
of it already to reject this claim
because it's completely false the
government taking its time is nothing
new it took nearly a week with multiple
clarifications to State cada's position
on the case being brought forward in
large part because of the Electoral
ramification not nine of the top 10
ridings with the highest Jewish
populations are liberal seats and the 10
largest Muslim populations are all
represented by liberals it continues to
be a profoundly divisive issue among
Canadians but especially among uh the
ranks and of the current liberal base
the conservatives have said it's Hamas
committing a genocide but had no comment
on today's ruling but the NDP did
calling on the government to tell Israel
to comply with the Court's decision
people are losing their lives and Canada
has an obligation and and I I feel very
much like the government is trying to
sort of sit on the fence the Liberals
tight rope position on the conflict will
be put to the political test later this
year when a byelection takes place in
Toronto St Paul's Neu one of those
liberal writings with a large Jewish
population McKenzie gray in Ottawa
thanks
mckenzy Canada and the US are
temporarily pausing funding for the UN
relief Agency for Palestinian refugees
after allegations some of its staff took
part in hamas's October 7th attack the
humanity itarian agency fired several
staff members after Israeli authorities
provided information of their suspected
involvement the UN agency is doing its
own investigation the US state
department says the claims pertain to at
least 12 people the International
Development Minister says there will be
no additional funding from Canada while
the agency undertakes a thorough
investigation into these
allegations former US president Donald
Trump has been splitting his time
between courtrooms and the campaign
Trail late this afternoon a jury in New
York reached a verdict in his defamation
trial at issue whether Trump damaged
magazine columnist eege Carroll's
reputation by denying he raped her and
how much in Damages he should pay let's
bring in our Jackson prco now Jackson
the jury said the former president must
pay much more than the $24 million
Carol's lawyers had been calling for a
whole lot more NE through the Manhattan
jury ordered Trump to pay $83 million to
egene Carol for defaming her ever since
she made her original rape accusation
back in 2019 the settlement includes $1
million to fund a reputational repair
campaign and another 7.3 million for
emotional harm that she suffered during
the course of the trial Carol testified
that she was frightened by persistent
attacks from Trump and his supporters
and that her reputation was shattered
now this is the second award she has
received after a different jury found
Trump liable for sexually AB using her
back in the mid 90s in a department
store dressing room Trump says he's
going to appeal he calls this a Biden
directed Witch Hunt which is not at all
true remember this was a civil suit
brought by a private individual and the
damages were awarded by a jury of
ordinary citizens but given the
ferociousness of Trump's attacks the
judge offered this advice to jurors
never disclose that you were on this
jury you to and as this has been going
on Trump has also been fueling tensions
over illegal migration along the US
Mexico border Jackson we know that in
December alone roughly
250,000 migrants crossed the southern
border into the us but where do things
stand today well with Trump's
encouragement Republican governors in
half of the country are now backing
Texas in this legal standoff with the
federal government and it's intensifying
concerns about a potential
constitutional crisis in the
making the razor wire on the southern
border is a sharp message of defiance
from Texas where the governor ordered
the state's national guard to block
migrants from crossing the Rio Grand
claiming Texas faces an invasion what
Texas is asserting is our Article 1
Section 10 right of self-defense the
Supreme Court disagrees this week it
ordered Texas to allow Federal border
patrol agents to remove the wire what we
want is border patrol to be able to do
their jobs and right now Governor Abbott
is getting in the way Texas won't back
down and is refusing Ching to
acknowledge the Court ruling or federal
authority over the border the appearance
of Asylum Seekers and even large amounts
of Asylum Seekers at the border is not
the type of invasion that the
constitution talks
about make no mistake this is entirely
about election year politics Republicans
under Donald Trump want to make
migration the central issue in the
presidential campaign 25 republican-led
states are now backing Texas some have
sent their own National guard troops to
the Border in doing so they've brought
the US to the brink of a constitutional
crisis this is the exact thing that the
United States went through in its first
70 to 80 years of existence leading to
eventually the secession of states and
the Civil War back in Washington a
bipartisan group of lawmakers is working
on a border Bill to deal with the record
surge in migrants but hopes of passing
the legislation have fallen apart As
Trump signals he wants to campaign on
Border chaos the idea that someone
running for president would say please
hurt the country so I can blame my
opponent and help my politics is a uh a
shocking uh uh
development and you know the delay on
passing a border Bill isn't just adding
to the tension in Texas aid for Ukraine
and Israel are tied up here too so
Republicans who worked on that bill are
now worried that if they're trying to
keep Trump happy but fail to pass the
Bill they'll actually end up wearing
blame for the crisis at the border by
the time the election rolls around in
November me to Jackson prco in
Washington thanks
Jackson an Ontario man accused of
sending lethal substances to people at
risk of self harm is facing upgraded
first-degree murder charges Kenneth
Law's lawyer says he will plead not
guilty to all 14 upgraded murder charges
law is also facing 14 counts of
counseling or aiding suicide within
Ontario Police allege he operated
several websites selling sodium nitrate
a substance that can be toxic in large
doses investigators suspect he sent more
than 1,200 packages of supplies to 40
countries including 160 in Canada alone
if you or someone you know needs help
you can call or text 988 Canada's new
suicide crisis helpline the service is
available in both English and French 24
hours a day every day a Quebec Superior
Court Judge has refused to Grant an
injunction that would have halted tree
cutting east of Montreal at the site of
a future electric vehicle facility it's
a decision Canada's industry Minister
welcomes for the future of the country's
EV
industry and for me this is a flagship
project that shows to quebecer to our
young people that you know what you can
care about the the environment and at
the same time do well from an economic
perspective and so I hope people will
sit in the broader context the judge
ruled Swedish company northv had all the
necessary permit to continue its
Preparatory work last week the company
voluntarily paused work when an
environmental group and three citizens
filed an injunction the project was
announced in the fall touting production
of some of the greenest batteries in the
world environmental groups are concerned
about the impact on the area's
biodiversity disturbing accusations
against the founder of the WWE coming up
the explicit claims leveled at Vince
McMahon
in the world of pro wrestling Vince
McMahon was the Kingpin and a big part
of the show now the World Wrestling
Entertainment founder is being accused
by a former employee of sex abuse
trafficking and exploitation Eric senson
looks at the Fallout from the lawsuit
what it could mean for McMahon's future
and the wrestling Empire he
started don't tell me you don't care who
I am I'm Vince McMahon in public it was
all a show big ego ill-tempered at times
abusive off camera according to a
lawsuit Vince McMahon was all of that
and much much worse Janelle Grant says
McMahon hired her at WWE World Wrestling
Entertainment where she says she was
sexually and emotionally abused and
trafficked to other employees the suit
shows alleged texts from McMahon with
obscene descriptions of sex acts with
grant grant names McMahon and another
executive John laurenitis alleging she
felt trapped submitting to McMahon's
sexual demands or facing ruin alleging
others at the WWE knew what was going on
and actively sought to conceal the
wrongdoing a spokesperson for McMahon
gave a statement to online news Outlet
wrestling Inc this lawsuit is repl with
lies obscene madeup instances that never
occurred he will vigorously defend
himself though WWE's parent company TKO
group says we take Miss Grant's horrific
allegations very seriously and are
addressing this matter internally John
Pollock has a wrestling podcast I don't
think anyone could have been adequately
prepared for just how dark of a series
of allegations as these were over the
last 40 years McMahon has transformed
what critics call an imitation Sport Pro
Wrestling into a macho sexualized
over-the-top billion dooll entertainment
Empire the justice department is charged
Vincent McMahon of Connecticut McMahon
has been in trouble before accused of
Distributing steroids to wrestlers in
the
1990s two years ago the WWE board looked
into claims of sexual misconduct and
secret payments made to Grant and other
women by McMahon he has had a certain
tefl long quality about him to get
through certain controversies but I
think many are wrestling with that
portion of Vince McMahon that has become
so public and impossible to avoid
tonight there are calls for the larger
than life face of pro wrestling to step
away from the world he created and the
organization he built Eric senson Global
News
Toronto a high ranking member of the
Roman Catholic Church in Quebec is
facing allegations of sexual assault
court documents filed yesterday as part
of an ongoing class action lawsuit
authorized in 2022 against the arch
dicese of Quebec City alleged Cardinal
Gerald lacro the current Archbishop of
Quebec City touched a 17-year-old girl
without consent the allegations date
back to 1987 and
1988 ahead a major update on the health
of King
[Music]
Charles Pope Francis again tried to
clarify the vatican's landmark ruling
that allowed priests to administer
blessings to same-sex couples in an
address address to Vatican members the
pontiff says the blessings are not meant
to justify the unions instead they are
meant for the people involved to get
closer to God the December ruling
sparked widespread debate and push back
throughout the Catholic Church which
still considers gay sex as
sinful King Charles is recovering after
undergoing a scheduled corrective
procedure for his enlarged prostate the
75-year-old Monarch is expected to spend
at least one night in hospital Charles
is at the same facility as Kate the
Princess of Wales she had abdominal
surgery last week Queen Camila appeared
in good spirits as she left the hospital
saying the king is doing well last week
Buckingham Palace revealed the king's
condition is
benign dancing for democracy next
Ukraine's National Ballet tours Canada
raising awareness for those back
[Music]
home
the National Ballet of Ukraine is
touring Canada its first tour in North
America since Russia's fullscale
invasion of Ukraine almost two years ago
the constant threat of attack almost
permanently closed the curtain on the
ballet company but as Heather urx West
explains the dancers have found a way to
keep the performance
going sharing the stage with images of
War Ukraine's National Ballet has an
important story to tell for us it's a
very big opportunity for all company and
for all
dancers that opportunity to share with
audiences across Canada that after
almost 2 years of war Ukraine's National
Ballet is still going strong though it
hasn't been an easy Road a lot of people
left our our country and a lot of
artists left our
country in the early days of Russia's
fullscale Invasion the company saw its
numbers fall from 150 artists to less
than 30 but as the months went by the
ballet found a way to dance on even when
air raid sirens in ke would force
performances to pause sending dancers
and Their audience underground we see
consistently throughout the uh conflict
in Ukraine that the destruction of
culture has actually been a really key
feature so we've seen museums looted we
have seen
um concert Halls just like the one we're
in right now completely
destroyed it's why this tour titled Nida
or hope Ukraine means so much to so many
not just to the dancers themselves but
to those displaced ukrainians currently
calling Canada home we actually have the
great privilege of inviting about 500
refugees uh to the show in uh Montreal
we invited them free of charge just so
they could get a little bit of Taste of
Home the tour is also about raising
awareness and funds in the middle of
winter and ravaged by years of war
Ukraine is in the midst of a
humanitarian
crisis audiences in 10 Canadian cities
will enjoy their performances as
Ukraine's national ballet dances for
their people whether displaced around
the world or living through War back at
home Heather urix West Global News
Calgary and that is global national for
this Friday night I'm Nara tonight's
your Canada is this bird's eye view of a
frozen trout lake in North Bay Ontario
we love seeing your Canada please email
your photos to viewers
global.com thanks so much for watching
and hope you'll join us again tomorrow
have a great
[Music]
night